when you think of crypto traders what do
you think do you imagine young guys and
hoodies living in their parents
basements
yeah maybe in 2012
but today that stereotype is a bit
outdated crypto has gone corporate in a
big way
just last year professional money
managers bought and sold more than a
trillion dollars worth of crypto so
let's talk about the new cryptocurrency
market i'm going to give you the three
reasons that wall street has taken over
crypto
let's get into it
reason number one
fomo or fear of missing out when there's
money to be made folks on wall street
want to get their hands on it and crypto
is generating a lot of money the market
cap or total value of all cryptocurrency
investments is approaching two trillion
dollars that's tiny compared to the 40
trillion dollars or so of market cap on
the s p 500 but 2 trillion dollars is
still a lot of money and with crypto's
continued growth in the mainstream
acceptance there are lots of
opportunities for more management fees
trading commissions and other revenue
streams that wall street loves many also
see crypto as the first new asset class
in a generation that creates all sorts
of new opportunities for new clients and
more gains
reason number two the crypto market has
grown up
it used to be that to invest in
cryptocurrency you had to buy the coins
yourself or mine them and then find a
secure way to hold them today there are
crypto derivatives like futures options
and swaps plus plenty of exchanges and
market makers that make investing in
cryptocurrency a lot more palatable for
the risk-averse wall street crowd the
market has also grown significantly in a
short amount of time rising from a
market cap of around 150 billion dollars
in march 2020 to 1.7 trillion dollars in
march 2022
that growth means that professional
money managers can safely make big bets
without moving the entire market or
drawing undue attention these new
products and deeper markets also make it
possible for firms to make money on
crypto through price volatility so they
win whether prices go up or down that
wasn't possible when all you could do
was buy or sell tokens reason number
three
there are a growing number of crypto
converts on wall street just like more
everyday people are starting to believe
in crypto more professional investors
are as well my colleague gregory
zuckerman reported earlier this year
that billionaire hedge fund manager paul
tudor jones's firm is investing in
crypto as a way to protect against
inflation european hedge fund brevan
howard has even created a cryptocurrency
division which manages over 250 million
dollars the 1.14 trillion dollars in
trading the professional investors did
in 2021 for crypto exchange coinbase was
almost 10 times the amount of trading
they did in 2020 and it's more than
double the 535 billion dollars in
trading done by retail investors
according to my colleague paul vina that
shows just how big a slice of the crypto
pie wall street is taking none of that
means that crypto is guaranteed to make
you rich or that it's a totally safe
investment now just because wall street
is doing it doesn't mean it's a good
idea just know that more trades in the
crypto market are being made by folks
who look like this
than folks who look like this if you
enjoyed this video be sure to like and
subscribe and i encourage you to be like
the great warren g who said shake the
spot with my knot
may fade because i don't like to dream
about getting paid
i'll see you next time